okay let's return to our top story the
train crash in egypt where at least
32 people have been killed let's bring
in middle east analyst yahya kanem he's
joining us live
from doha good to have you with us i
understand that uh
president abdulfatah el-sisi is now
promising punishment for those
who have caused this accident um
given the circumstances regarding
egyptian railways and what it appears to
be the case that there are
they are badly underfunded and there are
regular accidents
is punishment the right route to go no i
don't believe
it's the right to the right thing to do
and it's not the right way to go
i believe there is a serious serious
problem and serious
issues when it comes to fundamental
services given to
the egyptian people including of course
the
uh the railway um it's it's
it is so sad and it's heartbreaking to
see
these kind of accidents happens on
sometimes even weekly basis
and all the egyptians
here is just as justification and talk
by the officials about the punishment
for
the train drivers and those people whom
i
do not in most cases see or hold
responsible the responsibility falls on
the system
on the regime on the president himself
the president
i remember seeing and hearing him in a
public rally
two years ago listening he was sitting
and listening to the head of the
the the authority of the railway when he
asked the president
for half billion half billion
u.s dollars to make this service
safe for the egyptians the president
mocked him
in public and he said half billion u.s
dollars to
make it safe if i put that amount of
money in any bank
how much do i get in return as an
interest
a country any country cannot be run as a
grocery store
or a department store the country and
the states are being run differently
the president doesn't know the basic the
basics of running a country like
egypt so i i believe they're talking
about the punishment
again as in all previous cases in
accidents and incidents punishment for
the drivers or the
small employees or low-ranking
employees is not good and it's not going
to fix anything
at all if i understand what correctly
what you're saying
it seems that the president and his
government are essentially out of touch
with what the regular people want one
would have thought
that for something so intrinsic to basic
life
within egypt such as a functioning
transport system which clearly
thousands of people use every day it
would be vitally important to make that
a priority and yet
we hear a great deal about other
construction projects that are mounted
in egypt at millions and millions of
dollars they seem to be bypassing the
rail network
why is that that they appear to be
having this
this blinkered approach towards what is
essentially
a key public service again the reason
for this
and let me quote the president himself
in a public rally
a year ago and
to my astonishment he was bragging he
was bragging in public
when he said that do you think i'm a
politician i'm not a politician
the man thinks that being a politician
is something
shameful and since the head of the state
doesn't want to be a politician of
course he doesn't have any idea about
the priorities and that's why
we are seeing all these meaningless
projects about the highest tower
in africa the biggest mosque in africa
or in the world the biggest
church in the world uh which are being
erected in the
his new uh capital uh
he's building right now and he spends
billions
billions of dollars on building this
this city
yeah we appreciate it as always thank
you very much indeed yahya ghanim
joining us
and al jazeera thank you